I just I couldn't sleep I just had to
solve this problem and that and that's
really what inspired me to start the
business my name is jewel Burks I'm
co-founder and CEO of part take and I'm
26 years old so I actually started my
career at Google I had some personal
things going on grandmother was
diagnosed with breast cancer and I
wanted to be closer to home so I decided
to sort of take a leap of faith moved
from California working at headquarters
and moved to Atlanta I was working at a
major parts distributor my grandfather
called me he is a farmer we have a
family farm in reps and Alabama and his
tractor broke down in the middle of his
harvest and he needs to find a part for
it and he called me because he thought I
could help him because I'm working at a
purse distributor and I come from Google
so shouldn't know how to search but I
could not find this heart and the fact
that he was having this problem and I
was also experiencing it every day at
work and people our customers were also
having the same problem that was really
kind of the straw that broke the camel's
back what we allow a user to do is snap
a couple pictures of a part that they're
looking to replace or find another one
of and with those images just typically
two images we can take out all of the
key features and figure out what exactly
the part is down to the part number the
finish all the characteristics of that
given part I didn't have the computer
science background I majored in
marketing at Howard University but what
I did have was knowledge of the industry
and also having worked at Google some
exposure to technology as a way to solve
problems and I've put those things
together and that's really how perfect
was started I was able to start hanging
around Georgia Tech and find some people
that could help me with actually
building it and then also my co-founder
was working at Shazam which is mobile
recognition for music and so we were
able to bring together our expertise and
just our experience to form part pick so
it's not just me it was a team of people
brings this idea to market